In einer Zeit, als das Vinyl
noch Schallplatte hieß,
war es so, dass viele Menschen diese
von Anfang bis Ende gehört haben.
Das scheint vorbei und vergessen.
Marc Engenhart und Duc-Thi Bui
haben sich erinnert
und vor zwei Jahren
ein Unternehmen ins Leben gerufen,
das sie PLAYTIME nennen
– „Spielzeit“.
Ein gesamtes Werk
– manchmal gehen die Alben
60, 70 Minuten –
nur zu hören,
ist heute ’ne besondere Erfahrung,
die wir wieder in die Kultur
und unter die Menschen bringen wollen.
Das ist eigentlich die …
die ursprüngliche Idee gewesen.
Wann immer PLAYTIME
in einem deutschen Kino
wie hier im Berliner „Babylon“,
angekündigt wird
bezahlen die Besucher fünf Euro dafür,
gemeinsam mit anderen Menschen
eine Schallplatte anzuhören.
An diesem Abend ist es das Album
„Blonde on Blonde“ von Bob Dylan.
Bei den diesjährigen
Kulturmarkenawards
wurde PLAYTIME sogar
als „Trendmarke 2016“ nominiert.
Die Idee, etwas bewusst und
ohne Ablenkung zu genießen, kommt an.
Das ist das, worum es eigentlich
bei PLAYTIME geht:
also die Zeit, um „Play“ zu drücken
und einfach zuzuhören und die Musik
ihrem eigenen Tempo zu lassen,
ohne dass man jetzt eingreifen möchte
durch Skippen oder Vorspulen oder
verführt wird von anderen
Möglichkeiten, anderen Songs
die nur einen Klick entfernt sind,
und sich einfach einer Musik hinzugeben,
von Anfang bis Ende.
Ein komplettes Album anhören,
das braucht Zeit
und es verlangt Muße.
Diese Ruhe haben heute
die wenigsten Menschen.
Wir sind heute kaum noch in der Lage
eine Aktivität über einen
längeren Zeitraum auszuüben.
Man lebt fast in einem
Zwei-Stunden-Rhythmus,
alle zwei Stunden muss
ein neuer Impuls folgen,
ob’s jetzt der Theater-Abend,
der Kino-Abend,
der Besuch von Freunden ist,
ob’s das Abendessen ist.
Alles ist sozusagen in einem
Zwei-Stunden-Rhythmus getaktet,
und dann brauchen wir etwas Neues.
Die Zeit, sie scheint uns
permanent wegzulaufen.
Das ist ein Phänomen unserer Moderne,
und doch ist dieses
Gefühl gar nicht so neu.
Schon vor rund 2000 Jahren haben sich
die Philosophen damit beschäftigt,
zum Beispiel der Römer Seneca.
Er ist damals davon ausgegangen –
und das trifft
für die Gegenwart sehr gut zu –,
dass ein Drittel der Zeit
ja uns genommen wird,
ein Drittel unbemerkt entschwindet
und ein Drittel zerrinnt.
Die Sehnsucht
nach Entschleunigung wächst.
Und die Menschen lassen sich viel
einfallen, um dem Stress zu entkommen:
Wellness-Oasen,
Urlaub mit Tieren in der Natur,
mitunter auch einmal ohne Mobilgeräte,
auch das Wandern wird populärer.
Die Verlangsamung –
sie wird zum Trend.
Es ist sicherlich noch
ein Nischen-Trend,
aber ich glaub,
er wird immer bedeutender,
weil die Bevölkerung schon merkt,
dass vieles eben zu schnelllebig
in unserer Zeit geworden ist,
diese Multioptionsgesellschaft, die wir
nun seit einigen Jahrzehnten haben,
uns vielleicht doch
ein Stück weit überfordert.
Zurück zum Kino „Babylon“ in Berlin:
Etwa 70 Minuten lang geht das Album,
dazu kommen die Pausen
beim Wenden der Schallplatten.
Keiner der Besucher
ist vorzeitig gegangen.
Ich find das superangenehm,
’n Album im Kino anzuhören,
und ich find’s auch sehr schön,
die richtige Lautstärke dafür zu haben.
Daheim sitzt man dann auch
und lenkt sich schon wieder ab
mit irgendwas anderem
oder mit irgend’nem Bildschirm
oder mit dem Handy oder sonst was,
während man Musik hört,
und so kommt man
einfach nur zum Musikhören.
Ich denke, das bringt
ein Musikverständnis zurück,
das wir unbedingt erhalten sollten.
Es ist sehr interessant.
Die PLAYTIME sind 70 Minuten Pause.
Und das ist, glaube ich, egal,
wann diese Pause stattfindet,
ob die morgens, mittags,
abends, nachts stattfindet.
Es ist ’ne Pause.
Die Ambitionen der
PLAYTIME- Erfinder sind groß:
Demnächst wollen sie ihr Konzept
auch in anderen
europäischen Großstädten vorstellen.